on the sidewalk hi we are here today to
talk about the Microsoft soundscape app
which is an application that allows
anyone with low vision or visual
impairment to be able to have mobility
and independence and to help me do that
I have a most Miller with Aloha with me
to really give us a real demo of this
application emmos you want to describe
soundscape soundscape is really cool
okay using a stereo headset it lets a
person who's blind or low vision here
where the landmarks are around them in
3d and in this way they can build a
richer awareness of their surroundings
and feel more independent and confident
to explore the world beyond what they
know that's pretty cool so it's kind of
like it paints what's around you in
sound that's exactly what it does shall
we try it out let's do it that's true
alright so you have the headset yes I
have the headset and you'll start by
pressing around me and just listen to
where the landmarks are and tell me
where you hang them on a smartphone
sunscribe effectively takes the same map
that you have running on the phone and
plays it again 3d sound is not cool that
is so awesome
that's so awesome so yeah I just
described everything around me and I was
able to sort of navigate you know I'd
get my take my in this case my gaze to
all of those places and get your
orientation so I think it said that you
need to make your way to building 34 so
we do that so shall we try with this
yeah yeah absolutely
with soundscape instead of turn-by-turn
instructions we will place an audio
beacon on building 34 so we can hear
where it started okay so this app knows
how to rendezvous with that beacon
exactly so we'll set the beacon okay
okay that's right you also do the same
yeah do exactly the same on the top of
the list you'll see building 34 access
ramps do that access ramp yeah
access ramp and on your right ear you'll
start hearing a clicking sound and you
hear that I got it so it doesn't give
you directions but it kind of gives you
the sound impulse
oh you walk hold on you're walking
around yeah let's turn towards the way
you're hearing the beacon yeah okay so
it's completely centered and you're hear
a bell sound that tells me we are
pointing at building 34 okay yeah now of
course we can't walk there's the road on
the way that's all right so let's walk
along the road and find a place to turn
right okay all right let's go you can
hear the beacon on your right yeah walk
along here so I know that I'll have to
at some point done right that's right
good haha
it says a mice's bus stop so that's that
basically telling me the because this is
your bus stop this is a bus stop that I
place - it would sound skip you can
place a marker on anything you care
about that's cool so you told me that
I'm right there and it's also so it
helps me personalize my mental map of
the space right but also gives me a cue
that we are getting close to the
intersection because I'm correct because
you know that this because there before
the landmark yeah
so I'll start queuing the dog to find a
crossing you might have received yeah
yeah crossing so you really work
together with the app as well as your
cars as well as the dog in this case
yeah I saved of course yes we are there
forward and now as the beacon
straightens that off right in front of
us you should be able to hear the beacon
right in front which tells us that we
are walking in a straight line towards
our destination yes Ward's yeah it's a
ramble they are there's a crossing to
our left now entering a parking lot the
interesting thing about a parking lots
out here is if you have very little to
work with
yeah when you navigate surgery it can
really plays an important role to help
you keep your irritation orientation
yeah yeah this is a very effective in
open open areas but the interesting
thing here is this can be useful for
anybody who's in a new space even if
you're fully sighted
that's right this is inclusive design in
action correct yeah because as you said
you knew you land up in a parking lot or
you land up in a campus that you don't
know anything about and obviously our
beacon campus our buildings are not
numbered in sequence very helpful good
boy Trevor and we are at the access ramp
that's right good boy that's awesome boy
that is really awesome fantastic thank
you so much everyone this is such a
wonderful work where can people go get
this app there are thousands of people
out there enjoying the outdoors with
soundscape every day and it's just
wonderful to see that happening people
can get the app for free on the iOS App
Store in the u.s. in the UK in Australia
and we're working to get it to other
countries as well it's awesome thank you
so much it's such a pleasure thank you
smiling they shake hands Microsoft